[Music]
hi once again I brought you two clips I
don't know why I feel the need to
imperil myself when I know I want to
talk about one-handed spiral reps which
a lot of fun and feel really cool and
you can do stuff like this and if you're
playing spy raps it's not that tough to
learn to do it one-handed
we're going to talk with the right hand
and we're gonna go into it from a
backward weave although you could do all
the same things for my forward weave but
we're gonna go from a backward weave
first thing is to find the moment where
you can do this with having neither poi
wrap around its own hand because if you
do that in one hand and not the other
hand that's usually where people have a
lot of trouble so you want to make sure
you can come with no wraps to that from
that moment you can play with just the
right hand going and then letting it
wrap around its own hand
now again you need to choose when it
started to wrap you could also go miss
and around your two fingers so you need
to miss and then go around the fingers
so once you have control of that what
you're going to do in the moment where
it wraps around its own hand you hit it
with the tether of the other place that
the other play begins to wrapped as well
so you go miss and then they will both
wrap up more or less evenly
apparently myself show that a little
closer maybe I miss and then they both
wrap and that gives me this nice even
wrap which if you do it really well
you can stop it and then release
dramatically um from a forward weave so
I was talking to G about this and he
agrees the forward wave seems to be
easier let's see why I don't know you
want to find from afford weave that
moment
where you would do this see it has
entrapped her on my own hand yet in that
moment you miss wrap around your right
hand then you missed right hand and let
the left pie also hit it and again you
really have to play with exactly where
you place your left poi to get them to
wrap evenly so I put the tether right at
the blade of my right hand and that
gives me a nice bang nice even wrap the
other one is for the other one I put it
right basically at the top of my hand
and that is about makes it even but
you'll have to play depending on the
size of your hands and your poi might
have to mess around with that so yeah
they're they're fun I I go in between
doing two Hamlet's pie wraps and one hem
Spile wraps I really like the fact that
with one hand you can go around a finger
two fingers and that can be great when
you want a really slow spiral wraps you
can go so what I told you a moment ago
about making sure you miss and then wrap
I realized immediately afterwards is
only partially true
you can wrap immediately the only
difference is whether you're going to go
as far as you can with the other hand or
hit early with the other hand and you
can totally make it work either way so
this shows you anything I say take it
with a grain of salt so you can miss and
wrap like this and get a nice wrap you
can also wrap right away and the other
plate just has to be out here enough to
also get a nice wrap and of course the
other one I haven't seen any updates you
just go right from say forward weave and
it works so reporting live from where
are we
Tenerife can I repay island in masca
gorge
[Music]